in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Josh
and limbs are with us hey guys how are
you pretty dessert
welcome welcome are you guys from
Madison Wisconsin good to have you and
you're here to do a debt-free screen
which are all the way in Nashville from
Madison and how much have you paid off
$13,000 very cool and how long did that
take nine months very good and your
range of income during that time we
started about 68 and we're on track to
be about 73 this year very good what do
you guys do for a living I'm a service
manager for a small auto repair shop and
I also am a pistol instructor outside of
that good for you okay cool
then I own a salon in Sun Prairie
Wisconsin and today is actually my five
year anniversary of being in business
for myself Wow way to go excellent very
cool so uh what happened nine months ago
that made you guys decide to get out of
debt Church basically our pastor when we
were going through our marriage
counseling had brought up FPU before I
didn't really have a time set for us and
one day I came home and she said hey
we're doing it and of course I'm being
an awesome husband that he is even
though I signed us up without talking to
him I knew if it's something that I
really want to do he'll do it yeah there
you go so you went through Financial
Peace University nine months ago we did
and then we finished our class in
November and started coordinating a
class in January Wow
thank you that's fun Oh worked out good
it worked out good for us yeah you know
it kept us accountable basically in
staying on track there's nothing no
better way to learn something than to
teach it that's correct I mean you
really it's amazing you probably learned
a lot about pistils why you've been
teaching them I have a bath now very
cool about how people must behave with
them go on YouTube right there middle
death yeah I mean it scared me to death
but anyway the so what kind of debt was
the thirteen thousand mostly credit card
and car payments we had some medical
bills but
student debt we're fortunate that way
but how long have you been married
little over four years okay so you're
about normal yep what's kind of trucking
along got two good careers things are
going good and a little bit of dad no
big deal and then she signed you up for
class that's probably how it's gonna be
the rest of my life at the same time
while we're trying to pay off debt we
are also cash flowing fertility
treatments doing that as well very cool
okay good how's that going going good
good we're on a good track
good yep I'm still going that's an
awesome perfect well congratulations
this is very cool how does it feel to
not have any payments I think it's gonna
take a little bit to set in we've made
our last payment last Thursday he texted
me at 233 and the afternoon saying took
the last check over to the bank
my car's paid off and that's it that's
it all right
car drives different without a payment
oh yeah yeah that's fun but you know
more than that thirteen thousand is is
it's a victory I mean your heroes you
knocked it out no question about that
but I'm guessing that no more than that
was that probably the sense of being on
the same page and being in controls a
bigger deal it is pretty much yeah
especially with babies in the offing and
that kind of stuff yes it gives you a
sense of power over your destiny doesn't
it it does very cool so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
find you go to church maybe yeah I have
some friends and we try to push them
into that that that group you know I'm
trying to go and do this and get on
board with financial peace and you know
we still run into the couple that
struggle because we're the same age
but it we just tell now I guess look at
us and go online and look at everybody
else's stories you know I mean I got it
done we got it done I think it can be
done as you were doing it what was the
most important things you did that
caused you to get out of debt I think it
was just tenacity we would be really
good we'd have our budget we'd be good
for a month and then the next month we
would totally blow it
and then just staying focused getting
back on track and going okay no we got
this we can back on track and we've made
it through finally yeah very cool well
congratulations you too thank you and
the next step of course is to finish the
emergency fund and then start your baby
step four five and six where you build
wealth and you actually start to really
kick in to the good part of money and
that is living like no one else so now
you later you can live like no one else
and give like no one else so we're gonna
give you a copy of a signed copy of
Chris Hogan's new book number one
bestseller retire inspired because
that's the next thing that's that's
where you go next and so congratulations
very very well done thank you alright
Josh and lens from Madison Wisconsin
thirteen thousand dollars paid off in
nine months making 68 to 73 count it
down let's hear a debt free scream 3
hold on you guys that's how you do it I
love it I love it I love it
very cool hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common